well i think this country um has given
me everything uh i have uh lived the
british dream i came here
at the age of 11 couldn't speak a word
of english um headed the back of the
class okay and of course
very quickly learned to read and
speak the language but actually think
and dream in the language
and i want to deliver the opportunity
for every
child in our country every family it's a
difficult time at the moment for our
country
we've got to rebuild the economy and
we've got to get it growing again
it's
a time of
economic
hardship it's a national crisis in the
way we've just been through the pandemic
which was another challenge for us
no one anticipated war on our continent
you know wars were sort of
uh conducted in far-flung places we now
have war on the continent of europe um
this is a dangerous time and i think i
am best suited to be able to
steward the economy through this and of
course look at where we can help more uh
you promised when you were education
secretary that teachers would get a nine
percent pay rise that's what you would
be hoping for will they get their money
no your chancellor
so in the manifesto we made a promise
that uh starting pay for teacher will be
30 000 pounds a year the nine percent
begins to deliver that um and then we
need another seven percent next year to
complete that i pledge that i will do
that that was my submission to the pay
review bodies but but i'm asking more
senior teachers
to take five percent over two years uh
i'll as chancellor we'll look at the pay
review body
from across government and we'll make a
decision together my message to all
public sector workers is look we i feel
your pain but we've got to come together
because if we don't bear down inflation
now
it will hurt us even more in years to
come that's why i think we have to be
fair but firm on fiscal discipline and
get the headroom so that we can then
inject that growth in the economy for
sme small businesses and of course for
people in terms of
their own
taxation so junior nurses can expect
nine percent as well
well i will look at um what the pay
review bodies will uh do for uh nurses
and for the rest of the um uh public
sector and i will with my cabinet
colleagues make a decision again my
message is we have to maintain that
discipline and come together in this
really difficult time it is a national
emergency
and if we do this well we'll come out
the other end a lot stronger if we bear
down our inflation and inject that
growth into the economy okay so mr hunt
mr javid both saying they'll cut taxes
uh including the increase that we've
seen in national insurance and cut
corporation tax to 15
from 19
will you do the same i'm looking at
everything i said it when i took on the
role of chancellor um nothing's off the
table i'm looking at uh corporation tax
my concern with the corporation tax rise
to 25
is the one tax i used to sit on the
board of a foot c250 company
the one tax that international investors
can compare globally is corporation tax
and investment decisions are taking
over a long term
so my concern was we were beginning to
head towards a place where we are
perceived to be on the high end of
corporation tax and i want to look at
how we bring that back down but i need
the headroom by making sure i exercise
fiscal discipline and bring down the
cost of government to give me the head
room to make those changes but i
nothing's off the table and i want to
look at of course the um uh
19p they're bringing down uh income tax
from 20 to 19 19 p see what more i can
do on that smes small businesses
we've got a business rate review i want
to look at how we can help
businesses
the small businesses not just the large
ones
to get through what i think is
genuinely an economic national emergency
okay um just just to clarify um mr hunt
mr jabid we're hoping we'll commit to an
on-camera debate with us um on sky will
you do the same
i would certainly commit to an on-camera
debate
you say you want to cut taxes and
increase spending but how are you
actually going to fund that
so when i was in the department of
education
department of education is a large
department
we have 8 000
400 people in the department every
department was asked to look at um
reducing the cost by 20
it was a tough exercise
we looked at how can we continue to
deliver our pledges in the manifesto and
skills schools families which is so
important investment in skills t levels
as famous as a levels making sure we
deliver family hubs in half of england's
local office i understand all that right
but i managed it i managed to get close
to that number
i want all of my colleagues now as
chancellor
to do the same thing if i can bring down
the cost of government and be
disciplined around public sector pay we
just talked about public sector pay
i think i can have enough headroom
to be able to deliver the tax cuts on
the other side why is that right
because if you bring down the cost of
government you bear down on inflation
because that
is equally important okay
i have to deal with inflation
and of course lower taxation look
ultimately
a conservative economic policy
is one of lower taxation it works we
know it works historically that is what
i would do okay well let me try and ask
the question in a different way then
what services would you cut
to cut to fund tax cuts so i just
described to you my experience i was the
secretary of state for education yeah
i'm asking you about other departments
so what so what i'm we'll ask every
secretary of state and
the returns should already be in because
boris actually asked all of us to do
this um i will go through those returns
from each department to see how we can i
managed an education to get close to
that number that the the ask of me
tough
but i could maintain what i needed to do
in terms of what i want to deliver on
skills schools family uh and of course
um the cross-cutting issues like
recovery from the pandemic with national
tutoring program
the uh send green paper the but the
health services the health department's
not going to be able to cut their budget
are they so
that's your style health department now
under steve barkley i
can tell you there is none better than
steve barkley in being able to focus uh
his uh
laser-like focus on
looking at where inefficiencies are
and making sure he delivers those uh
cost savings that the health department
uh i'm certain can do so you think
there's some flab in the health service
well i i think it's only right that
across government um
we do this exercise it's an important
exercise it's only right that we
exercise fiscal discipline when it comes
to public sector pay
why because if we do that we can bear
down on inflation that in itself brings
down inflation so you're saying 20
cotton in every department well
that's what i want to make sure we get
to that will give me the head room to be
able to deliver tax cuts which i want to
deliver okay an emergency budget
um
i don't think
um i need an emergency budget we are in
the middle of a
um leadership uh campaign there's a
caretaker government at the moment if
things change and i've discussed this
with my perm secretary uh tom scholar
then of course i will you know take
whatever action necessary we need to ask
you about your um investigation into
your own uh tax affairs um what was your
reaction when you saw reports that your
own tax affairs were being investigated
by your own department so i was
clearly being smeared i was being told
that that the serious ford office that
the national crime issue that hmrc are
looking uh into me i've yeah i'm not
aware
of this i will i've always declared my
taxes i paid my taxes in the uk uh i
will
answer any questions hmrc has uh uh uh
of me but i will go further okay
i'm gonna make a commitment today that
if i am prime minister
i think the right thing to do is to
publish my accounts annually that's the
right thing to do because i think we
need to take this issue in many ways
off the off the table um i will publish
my accounts annually that's the right
thing backdated to do
i will look at you know what what the
options are in terms of back dating or
just publishing annually i think it's
right to do it what about your tax
returns
that's what i'm talking about my
textbook i'll publish annually okay
over the last decade
well if i'm prime minister i'll i will
publish them um going forward i don't
think being retrospective is right you
know i was in business before i came out
of that of course i'm now in politics is
it true that your family benefits from
an offshore
trust my family does not benefit from an
offshore i don't benefit from an
offshore trust nor does my wife
we don't benefit at all from that
my mother and father live abroad um
that's
their their business they're not they
don't live in the united kingdom have
you ever had non-dom status i've never
had non-dom status have you ever used an
offshore company to avoid tax never have
you offered them how's your family my
family my wife has never been non-dumb
she's never used offshore status or a
company to avoid tax have you told us
everything about your business affairs
that could potentially impact on your
future ability to be prime minister yes
i have have you ever used offshore
companies or services firms based in tax
havens for the purchase of property or
properties in the uk no i have
have you fully declared all of your
properties in the mps register of
interest
yes we have did you pay the requisite
taxes including stamp duty when
purchasing properties yes
uh
you
or your company once held 20 million
pounds of hugo shares in a
gibraltar-based company
what was the reason for using offshore
financial structures like this if not
for the purpose of avoiding tax i was
not the beneficiary of
the
balshaw
investment that held those uh shares um
and who was my family it's it's the
public record um uh my my father but why
would you do that if it wasn't for the
purpose of avoiding time because he's he
lives abroad he doesn't live in the
united kingdom okay two final questions
if i may just to clarify 110
obviously your chancellor so you know
you can't be 110 but just work with me
here um there is no way that any
funds are being funneled
into your parents accounts or whatever
so to keep your hands clean
absolutely fine
um
thank you for answering those questions
um
very great pleasure it's important
because i'll tell you why because you
know of course you know i've been in
business i've been a successful uh
businessman and um entrepreneur and i
think uh it's important that um
we have this discussion but when i'm
prime minister i think it's equally
important
to make the pledge that i will publish
my accounts annually my tax returns and
but not backdated well i just think
being retrospective is is is very
different you know i'm it's when you
take that's what people want to
know i i listen i declare my taxes um to
hmrc i will answer any questions from
hmrc that is a pledge uh i make it's
important that we have um okay prime
minister that is able to to do that i
think it'll make a difference to the
country okay going forward if all prime
ministers publish their tax returns yeah
hopefully you realize it's important for
me to ask the questions several
different ways just to make sure that
it's all covered you are um a very rich
man
how rich are you
um
so i've been very lucky i've self-made
i
have done really well
by investing in the united kingdom
and then of course
my wife uh now continues to invest in
the united kingdom directly in
uk companies
uh back to mark margaret hodges question
um and we we've grown
our investment here um that's i think a
good thing um and it should be
celebrated i'm the beneficiary of the
british dream um but i am i am wealthy
you're absolutely right can you tell us
how often you are well i i don't think
it's right to sort of go into numbers
because i will probably you know get it
wrong
is that because you're so wealthy no
because because these things move around
because you know some of the
assets that that my wife now obviously
controls in the uk because we invest you
know heavily in she does in the united
kingdom fair to say you're comfortable
for the rest of your lives we're i'm
very lucky we are very confident can a
single mom in walls end or wigan believe
you have her best interests at heart
given how wealthy you are
yes she can because i tell you how
because i've seen um hardship my father
lost everything my home our home
was repossessed
we had a nothing left other than a
vauxhall
senator brown voxel center car
where i had to make the choice as to
whether i go to university or become a
taxi driver
my mum wouldn't let me become a taxi
driver mini cab driver in the vauxhall
because that's all we had left um she
said no you go to university i read
chemical engineering i came out i've
been very lucky
in business and done incredibly well
so
i've seen it both ways i am self-made
and i think
what really drives me is delivering the
opportunity
for that mother and uh wigan or also
and of course for her children um and
other children around the country we
held cabinet a few weeks ago in
stoke-on-trent
in the three constitutional slogans
there's only one outstanding school that
can't be right i don't believe the
children in stoke on trent are any less
talented than the children of stratford
haven or in south kensington they just
don't have the great school with a great
teacher
and that opportunity to make something
of their lives and i'm determined to
deliver that
we've talked about this before but you
did
claim for heating the stables where the
horses were um you did pay it back um
you said it was a mistake but is that
really the point
it was a mistake because we bought my
wife and i a
cottage
with a riding school
there was a electricity meter in the
riding school there was an electricity
meter in the cottage um
i was um uh
told by the the then chief whip that you
should claim for your uh you're allowed
to feel basic running costs um
it's the right thing to do even if you
don't think um you need it um i put in
the claim
genuine mistake not realizing that
actually although there was two meters
it was coming in on a single bill um
when it became public
there was um a a an investigative full
investigation into this uh by the palm
tree of authorities they could see it
was a genuine mistake
and they agreed with me that was a
complete error mistake
um and of course i apologized and repaid
it embarrassed of course deeply
embarrassing um but it was a genuine
mistake it's much better to to to you
know
admit and
demonstrate um than to do anything else
okay let me give you that
you've run out of water um
let's talk about the president's club
uh
it was an event in 2018 in the
dorchester just up the road here
waitresses um female staff said that
they were groped um you were there
what did you see
so i was children families minister and
i was invited because this was a charity
that raises over a million pounds for
children's hospital like great ormond
street hospital
i
arrived there
and
just after nine
it was an all-male
black tie do it the dorchester and just
after 9
young ladies hostesses
that
came around each table which made me
feel incredibly uncomfortable which is
why i
left
the uh dinner
and and went home
and
you know
i think in
reflection
um
including the charity itself uh those
sort of you know all male dinners are
wrong um and i think actually you know
one of the things
that i'm passionate about is that we
treat people properly including people
who are there to serve us um
you know whether
in government or elsewhere and i think
i've got a strong track record whoever
i've worked with um in government um
will tell you that i treat people with
respect i treat them properly i engage
with them because we are a team that is
how you deliver your great public
services by working as a team what would
you say to your sons if they were
thinking about going to an event like
that don't go
how would you deal with
chronic sexual misbehavior in the party
so i think it's really important that
people who work
for members of parliament
for the party
are
well protected
that we have
really strong
um hr
that they always feel they can
speak to someone if they're feeling
vulnerable if they're feeling in some
way um you know
threatened or
mistreated
and i will promise you this
that across government if i am prime
minister i will
bring a an independent um
team they're available in the private
sector they do all the time in in large
organizations that will review
all of our
practices because
a professional
hr
department in government
is really important and i know the civil
service agrees with me on this
it's really important that we sort of
restore that faith that you know
everyone in the team you know a junior
member of staff um uh you know a middle
ranking member staff can always feel
that they work in a positive environment
there should be no place um for abuse or
people feeling threatened or in some way
entering the environment that's just not
quite safe that is just
unacceptable
is it acceptable
that the education minister andrea
jenkins um flipped her middle finger up
to the public as she walked into downing
street last week
no i don't think it is and i think
andrea
put out a statement
apologizing and explaining that um
uh she um had you know
felt emotional and and she'd have been
threatened um many times in the past but
it's not right um would you have
discipline her if you were still
um education secretary i i think it's
important that you know we help hold
ourselves to the highest standards what
i did in education okay i hope you'll
agree um was to sort of you know make
sure that
teachers felt valued that that
parents felt her children felt um both
you know safe and i able to learn what
would you have disciplined her well
i i think it was wrong i would have
asked her to to immediately
apologize um for her actions um how
important is loyalty to you given your
actions with the prime minister
over the last week
very important and i think i remained
loyal till the end in fact
when i and many other colleagues went to
see him on wednesday night and i sat
with him i said to him i've known you
for 30 years
you know
you're going to they're going to try and
humiliate you and i can't bear seeing
you being humiliated
i want you to to to just
explain to you what i think is about to
happen
and and i hope you will consider it and
um you know do this with dignity um he
wanted to um
can carry on
uh and um i left and the next morning i
felt very strongly i had to then put it
in writing just to repeat to him when i
that conversation in the evening
and then help him make that decision i
think he's sadly um uh in many ways um
uh you know uh
has had to resign uh his uh uh position
and of course
we are now into a leadership campaign so
what do you say to the backbenchers who
you need to rely on in order to be prime
minister you need their votes um what do
you say to those who say you were
treacherous you were
almost brutus-like
um
i don't i don't believe
uh that's true i all my life
um i have tried um to serve my country
the country that's given me everything
when asked to do the vaccines i stepped
up when i was to become sexually safe
for education i stepped up when he asked
me to become his chancellor i stepped up
we were making preparations for this
week's uh presentation that he and i
were going to give of how we're going to
create that headroom and bring those
taxes down that he really wants to see
us deliver on
alas we couldn't do it and when i saw
the writing on the wall where so many
ministers resigned it was you know
becoming impossible to form a government
um iron number of senior colleagues you
know i mean his chancellor after all it
i think it's my duty
to uh actually sit with him and say
both as a friend of 30 years and his
chancellor this can't carry on what are
your relationship like with him now
yeah i missed chancellor very we we
speak almost daily
um it's a full-time job being a
chancellor of course um running the
country um as far as its finances are
concerned it's a full-time job running a
campaign
are you going to consider resigning as
chancellor
quite the opposite
the first thing that
my perm secretary said to me tom scholar
is
chancellor
you
are needed we can't run we can't steward
the country without a chancellor being
in place um and uh my focus very much at
the moment is to make sure
we
continue
albeit in a caretaker government
to steward
the economy
and i hope
then if i'm returned as prime minister
to be able to rebuild the economy and
deliver some of those
tax cuts that i think i can deliver
whilst bearing down on inflation um and
i think i'll be able to do
both those things fine um who's your
hero
my heroine is margaret thatcher i'll
never forget
we arrived here on these shores in 1978
in 79 of course she became a prime
minister my mother saying
a grossest daughter my son has just
become a prime minister in this great
country that has
given us a home and has adopted us you
can do anything in this great country
and
an immigrant boy from baghdad who can
speak a word of english is now
chancellor the exchequer and uh is you
know having a uh
a a go at trying to become prime
minister this is the greatest country on
earth okay
good to talk to you thank you very much
indeed chancellor thank you